[Music]
and kill him with kindness news kill em
with kindness I don't do that submitted
by I just kill uncle feel rested piece
of Uncle feel Bob real the only father
that I ever nood sarah silverman
responded to a troll with kindness and
it was beautiful yeah Sarah Silverman is
the girl with the voice like this yeah
she was dating Jimmy Kimmel Fuhrman
she's a stand-up comedian yeah yeah I
feel like she always had a mustache I'm
pretty sure she did it looks promising
okay peach fuzz actress not just me
probably not anymore but when she first
started I saw her standing up I wasn't a
big fan of it but it's just a different
style no I I don't know the style at
that her stuff was very honest tunnel
now
well yeah it's been like a decade no way
more than that she was popping weight
like a Chinese villain right there
Vaizey in the [ __ ] rush hour so she
hate her voice but then I've grown to
like it she ended up tweeting so it's
all started with this pup tweet up here
so she was responding with someone who
said I'm really interested to what
degree she does understand someone of
the other team hmm and she responds with
I'm open sometimes all I know is they
have avatars like yours what is that
about why not your beautiful face and
then this guy named Jeremy responds with
[ __ ] and then she responds I believe in
you I read your timeline and see what
you're doing and your rage is thinly
veiled pain but you know that I know
this feeling PS my back [ __ ] sucks to
see what happens when you choose love I
see it in you so what she's talking
about is that and his Twitter feed is
just like a whole bunch of complaining
hate like he's just like spreading hate
like crazy and he's like talking about
how like his back is messed up he has
like like this like yeah and so like
huge just like he's just like a really
angry person like he posts a lot of like
metal songs that are just rage induced
and so that's what's just referring to
on his timeline so he responds with I
can't choose love a man that resembles
chemist Basie took that away when I was
8 I can't find peace if I could find
that
who ripped my body who stripped my
innocence I'd kill him he [ __ ] me up
and I'm poor so it's hard to get help so
then she says questions parenthesis and
all caps not judging are you doing
heroin
are you self-medicating do you want to
get clean no I just smoke weed on
prescribed medications which I take part
of me she says good I want to kill him
too so I can't imagine your rage all I
know is this rage and even if you could
kill him
it's punishing yourself and you don't
deserve punishment you deserve support
go to one of these support groups you
might meet your best bros there I will
go but I trust no one I've been burned
so many times I give the shirt off my
back and every time I get burned I'm
super antisocial I have no friends I'm
sorry I gave you [ __ ] dude I don't care
I'm fine I see something in you my gut
tells me you could have a great life my
shrink says we don't get what we want we
get what we think we deserve I'm telling
you you deserve so much more than you
know
lol how and what do you see I'm just
confused how you can see that I can do
better I have multiple problems a big
hole to crawl out of and usually I
choose not to express it or it's hard to
articulate my emotions haha honestly I
don't know all you wrote was cut but I
saw it and clicked on you and saw you
were just trying to get kicked off
Twitter
I saw the rage and pain and looked at
your avatar and just saw so much in you
in your eyes I guess don't know eyes are
the windows to the soul I don't want to
be like my drug addict thug ghetto
family I will try hard just apply the
disability and it really sucks I like to
work I'll get positive soon I've always
been negative hence no friends I'm an
[ __ ] but you're my [ __ ]
Prince C's wait so they just have like
the cemetery Commerce Wow that's really
nice of her to spend the time yeah
that's just the exact opposite what I do
I'm like [ __ ] you you dumb [ __ ] like I
know ah
not even like a angry way it's just more
like I want to see what they'll say yeah
it just becomes fun I'm like whoa what's
gonna happen next so for example on my
youtubes it was so [ __ ] funny there
was like this korean ahjusshi you know
had to be like 50 years old right he's
on YouTube yeah that's commented dude I
say bike the whole [ __ ] it was so [ __ ]
funny cuz I'm like taking a [ __ ] and I'm
saying
laughing my ass off and then I as I'm
typing to up he's just like I don't like
your condom your try too hard to be
ghetto and you're cursing shows that
you're very you're not intelligent I'm
my dude honestly how old are you it's
like 1:00 a.m. in the morning right I
like where's your kids like does your
wife
is your wife telling it was okay to talk
right now Matt he just goes like he goes
are you saying being a douche it's bad
all odds she's out there just to let you
know he doesn't like age discrimination
[ __ ] yeah so I just kept on like you
know obviously like this irritating him
just riding in big caps but I was like
laughing in tears because it was like
it's a video his channel has videos of
him just this is my office
[Laughter]
trying to make him as angry as possible
but I guess it wasn't really your the
reverse troll yeah it was just [ __ ]
funny I don't know why I think it was
funny because he's like a 50 year old
man and he's sitting there trying to
tell me how I should live my life and it
was like he goes oh if you have kids I
bet you kids would be so proud that
you're cursing so much I'm like I don't
have kids laughing but she did a very
good job cuz I wouldn't have done that
yeah she they finished off this
conversation here with she tweets I'm so
psyched you'll go keep me posted don't
give up on yourself be brave enough to
risk getting burned it's what happens
when you fight for yourself but it's
worth it I promise and he responds with
lol thank you damn you're so insightful
you got a degree or something he's gotta
be a fan if he's following her right
he's not just some random guy talking
[ __ ] I mean all the people that way all
the people are right now that [ __ ] in
our comments they all follow us yeah
I've gotten like one recently like they
went out of their way to get a troll
picture and then put that in their thing
and then put like very intimate things
about like our lives in their whole
profile and then talk [ __ ] you like talk
[ __ ] on my pager or our page and then
just like ding bro like you're a big fan
like you can find that picture yet to
find the picture to know like there were
like a lot of details I'm like man
you're like a really big fan like I
really appreciate you I know you're
trying to spread a hate but I really
appreciate that you know all this stuff
and then he just like spotted why you
killed him with kindness I wasn't trying
to kill him with kindness but like I
just saw how like how much of his life
he invested was this on Instagram yeah I
think it was yeah I think it was like
like there was so much time invested in
creating a profile putting it all that
everybody would you even follow tyka
like oh that's cool man yeah lol I've
always enjoyed your comedy but wow what
a contrast you got yourself a fan your
love for Humanity it's amazing it's so
there is that someone's like I enjoy
your comedy but then just five minutes
ago you little [ __ ] like in his on his
timeline - he was trying to write tweets
like why won't they ban me from Twitter
and like where do they just get off
Twitter them it's so interesting because
he has low self-esteem but he still
managed to take a mirror selfie which is
really awesome yeah yeah that means you
got it in you man if you could do that
MySpace mirror photo you still got it in
yet I wonder how much [ __ ] Sarah
Silverman have to go through to be able
to recognize that that's a cry for help
for real for me I would just get caught
up in it I play what the [ __ ] and I
would have to I can't even talk to sex I
just get mad but I would just hit the
block button yes I would do but for him
he's like I mean for her she was I can
tell that this is obviously a cry for
help when you reach out yes Jeremy oh
wow I pictured like a really like nasty
balding 50 year old guy with a broken
back he's a handsome dude yeah I
pictured like a really like people of
walmart kind of guy I told you herself
with seams not that bad this mirror
selfie takes a lot of confidence he's
got like it's style to like yo you got
something bro like hang in there sure
turn the flash off though maybe you like
the lens work looks like he works out
too and [ __ ] right the guy's got a low
self-esteem person works out man maybe
one that needs more affirmation I guess
but she didn't Rob
I don't know about that maybe the
construction worker please how about
dick it has all those slip disks oh
maybe that's what it is well yeah so
then Jeremy instead of post like
tweeting I'm raising money for back pain
relief click to donate he created a
GoFundMe and then sarah silverman like
quote retweeted it saying Jeremy went
for a consult and it's worse than we
hoped if you're so inclined help get him
on his feet and working again he's in
San Antonio if you're an actual expert
that can help with your skills so she's
even like helping him with his GoFundMe
that's dope she also offered to help
tell him jokes and [ __ ] make him happy
no she you see how she offered to pay
for his medical whoa damn damn she's
going above and beyond for someone that
like I would pretend that I'm helping
them so I could meet up with them and
[ __ ] hurt them
so now you know laters if Joe ever wants
to be kind to you and invite you don't
[ __ ] trap Hey Dude let's have dinner
I don't know about this oh that's genius
so Sarah like you're you're setting him
up and then like and then like you
collect the money and say huh you don't
get none
let me get anger issues bro oh that's
right they got two real silly as of now
he has three thousand one hundred and
twenty dollars in his go fund it for him
out of the one hundred and fifty dollar
goal yeah Oh fifty dollars you must be
really down and out you can owe $400
why don't you spend time on them that's
what I don't understand she's spending
all this time promoting and helping this
guy who called her a [ __ ] whereas like I
just ignore people that are hating and I
spent a lot of time on like if I see a
reoccurring
person that's commenting a lot in like
the positive fan
and then like they email me or whatever
then I spend the time like oh yeah you
know I don't know if I could get into
college and I'm like don't worry about
it man you could go to college you could
do anything you want you know like I'll
say that to that person because I feel
like they deserve that
communication versus someone who's like
hey Joe
you [ __ ] [ __ ] gobbler maybe she like
she said she just felt something you
know and maybe if she was in a position
once in her life where she was just
being a hater and she just connected
with you she's just more mature than I
am maybe she is giving positive fans
like attention to I don't know yeah
maybe she does both yeah she just goes
above and beyond yeah she's a variant
cuz the [ __ ] is just one word that's
just like that block and then you're
pretty good you know that's not
something that would like inside a
conversation out of me I don't like
negativity so as soon as I see I just
block it yeah like when you guys do
those comments do you actually click on
the profile like oh they are absolutely
like I just click on the profile to go
and block it if I write something to
somebody like that write something
really negative is nice very
entertaining is usually because I'm
taking a [ __ ] like no joke cuz that's
the only reason why I'll sit there the
skull through my phone and like you know
I actually do something so you know how
many people will be hitting me up and
saying like hey Bart blocked me can you
ask him to unblock me or David block me
like they they come to me I get from
David's yeah oh gee I like any of you
guys there they're always like oh can
you tell them like I'm gonna personally
go hey Bart um you know what there's
this kid that I think you should really
unblock no but then they get hella
anoying like please tell two o'clock man
like now you know it takes two because
they don't know what they said that got
them blocked and to be honest with you
90% the time is not because you said
something rude is because you made a
really bad joke and it just made me
cringe that's bad
[Music]